so npr a taxpayer-funded entity is now
pressuring facebook to suppress
daily wire and my facebook page
especially and directly
why not because we are presenting this
information but because we are
conservative
they're openly saying it it's right
there okay quote outrage as a business
model
how ben shapiro is using facebook to
build an empire now we've made no secret
of the fact
that facebook as a powerful social media
outlet is one of the places
where we push for traffic just as we do
on instagram just as we do on youtube
just as we do on twitter
just like every company does on all of
the major social media outlets
but it's bad that we're succeeding
according to npr that's the problem and
that must be stopped
this is a case that's now being
astroturfed by a wide variety of sources
who have decided that facebook is deeply
embarrassed of the fact they
they're suppressing information that we
are successful we're not suppressing
information that we're successful on
facebook or anywhere else thank god a
lot of people read our site
thank god a lot of people listen to the
show and they have every right to do so
and did it ever occur to npr and the
journalists
are so all fire concerned about people
viewing our content
that they are acting like authoritarian
idiots
did it ever occurred to them that i have
never said that npr
should be foreclosed the ability to
disseminate information
i think we should cut out funding i
don't see why i ought to pay for the
federal government to attack my site
that seems weird i don't see why
conservatives across the land
tens of millions of whom access our
content every month multiple times
i don't see why exactly they should be
funding npr to attack
the outlets they actually like to breed
and watch so npr has this piece it's not
about covered misinformation
it's about social media should shut down
daily wear because daily wire is daily
wire
quote in 2021 ben shapiro rules facebook
the conservative podcast host and
author's personal facebook page has more
followers than the washington post
and he drives an engagement machine
unparalleled by anything else on the
world's biggest
social networking site an npr analysis
of social media data found that over the
past year
stories published by the site shapiro
founded the daily wire received more
likes
shares and comments on facebook than any
other news publisher by a wide margin
even legacy news organizations that have
broken major stories or produced
groundbreaking investigative work
don't come anywhere close oh are we
hurting your feelings are we hurting
your feelings with the fact people like
clicking on our headlines
is it hurtful to you that the new york
times with its
with with honestly like the most
unreadable headlines in the news
business aren't getting clicked upon
maybe you should write readable
headlines that people give a crap about
maybe you should do that
or maybe the reason people are clicking
on our site as opposed to the vast
panoply of left-wing sites is because
there are many many left-wing sites in
like two
conservative sites maybe that's the
reason
or maybe the reason is because they
don't trust you
and your attempt to suppress information
and so they click on us more because
they don't trust you and they shouldn't
trust you
because you're a bunch of overtly well i
should say covertly partisan
it's i mean it's clear you're trying to
play this game where we pretend like we
don't see your biases
absurd here's the more of npr daily wire
articles with headlines like quote
book review proof that wokeness is
projectioned by nervous racist white
women who can't talk to minorities
without elaborate codes
regularly garner tens of thousands of
shares for the site and shapiro is
turning that facebook reach into a
rapidly expanding cost-efficient media
empire
one that experts worry may be furthering
polarization in the u.s
oh my god conservatives exist
polarization see this is it's so funny
this is how the left views polarization
polarization is usually
when people unfairly attack one another
and tell lies about each other
say like when the president of the
united states says you're a jim crow
segregationist because you like voter id
like that would be furthering
polarization but here's the thing for
the media
for the left their monopoly prevents
polarization because you see there's no
other point of view
if it is unipolar there is no
polarization if there is only one pole
there can be no polarization you see
it's amazing
if there's a monopoly on information and
everyone agrees with each other there's
no polarization inside the monopoly but
the moment
daily wire exists polarization it must
be stopped shut down daily wire
says npr again a taxpayer-funded entity
quote there's a demand among certain
subjects of the public for outraged
politics
said jamie settle the director of the
social networks and political psychology
lab
at the college of william and mary in
virginia this happens on both the left
and right but the people who do this on
the right have just found a lot more
successful ways of doing
halfway halfway because joe biden won 80
million votes on the basis that everyone
who had disagreed with him was a threat
to democracy and he's still saying it
the daily wire did not respond to
interview requests from npr for this
story yeah you know why because
that's why you think i don't know your
agenda before you start this crap
we know your agenda the moment you email
us as part of an astroturf effort
to force facebook into stopping the
dissemination of our website we know
exactly what you're doing everyone can
see what you're doing
the world's worst magicians don't even
misdirect with this hand just doing the
trick right here
says npr the site produces very little
original reporting our investigative
reporting team would beg to differ
people like
luke rosiak who have been breaking
stories from loudoun county but instead
mostly repackages journalism from
traditional news organizations with the
conservatives land
that alone wouldn't be newsworthy the
the circle of life online means
information
is written and rewritten in a seemingly
infinite loop
but the daily wire has turned anger into
an art form and recycled content into a
business model
wait no so so now the problem isn't that
we're lying and it's not that we're
doing anything different from anybody
else it's that we're good at it
oops i'm so sorry are we hurting your
feelings
here oh poor npr oh a little ball
so sad get out the world's tiniest
violin in may
the daily wire generated more facebook
engagement on its articles then the new
york times
the washington post nbc news and cnn
combined
yeah you know why because we're good at
our jobs
and because you guys kind of suck okay
that's the reality people don't like
your content and so they click on the
opposite content by the way if you think
the new york times the washington post
nbc news and cnn are having
media troubles in terms of like people
clicking on their sites
this is a complete misread i promise you
that all of the sites that you just
mentioned
have bigger traffic than we do overall
other conservative outlets like the
blaze breitbart news in the western
journal that publish aggregated and
opinion content
aimed at invoking outrage have also
generally been more successful
at generating engagement than legacy
news outlets over the past year
the success of those outlets on facebook
may also undermine conservatives often
repeated claims
that social media networks have an
anti-conservative bias
okay well i mean i can show you exactly
when and where the spigots get turned
off on our traffic because we watch it
every single day
so yeah no tracking the amount of
engagement a poster outlet gets on
facebook
is not the same thing as tracking the
number of people that content actually
reaches through the platform
in october facebook released data
showing that the sort of conservative
click bait that performs well in
engagement metrics was not actually
being seen by as many people
as articles from the more mainstream
news outlets
okay so in other words they're now
complaining that people click
on our headlines but don't read through
to the story so they're basically now
admitting that they
still get more traffic than we do but
we're still bad because we exist
the daily wire is clearly successful
this is well thanks we appreciate it
the company is growing and profitable
according to ceo jeremy boring who told
axios earlier this year the company
plans to expand more intense
entertainment and further build out the
daily wires smartphone app
while other publications have seen their
engagement numbers for facebook fall off
this year
the daily wire has stayed fairly
constant according to npr's analysis
i'm depressed by it but i'm not that
surprised said settle this has
everything to do with the psychology of
news consumers and the broader issues
with polarization in american culture
see again
the problem is polarization is caused by
us existing this this
article is just we exist daily aware
exists and people read it
polarization maybe it's polarizing that
you want to shut us down
maybe that's the polarizing aspect of
american politics these days again
for the one thousandth time i have not
called for npr's informational
informational distribution to be shut
down i've done so with regards to no
other media outlet but i'm noticing a
lot of people from these media outlets
want me shut down
weird how that works the articles the
daily wear publishes
don't normally include falsehoods and
the site says it's committed to truthful
accurate and ethical reporting
but as settle explains by only covering
specific stories that bolster the
conservative agenda
like negative stories about socialist
countries and polarizing stories about
race and sexuality issues
and only including certain facts readers
still come away from the daily wires
content with the impression republican
politicians can do little wrong
and cancel culture is among the nation's
greatest threats so in other words
again is npr saying you're a
conservative so you're bad they admit
that we are not saying anything false
they're just angry that we're
conservative
by the way the new york times only
covers specific stories that bolster
their narrative
they only tell you specific facts that
bolster their narrative
in the same way we do the difference is
we're honest and they're liars they'll
tell you their objective and we'll
we're conservative get over it
an npr review of stories on the daily
wire about the cove 19 pandemic over the
past few months found numerous stories
about potential side effects from covet
but none
that portrayed the scientifically
demonstrated efficacy of the vaccines or
which focused explicitly on the
hesitancy that has slowed the us roll
out
um wait hold up a second you're saying
that we are anti-vaxx are you insane
are you crazy listen to a single moment
of this show
okay the site routinely talks about the
efficacy of the vaccines
we do this all the time
often the site's headlines seem like a
conglomeration of conservative a
buzzwords this is reporting from npr
your taxpayer funded entity
cnn medical experts urges we must make
life hard for unvaccinated test them
twice weekly there's nothing false about
that headline
they tend not to provide much context
for the information they're providing
said settle
if you've stripped away enough context
any piece of truth can become a piece of
misinformation
there it is right there right everything
is misinformation because we don't like
how you are telling it
it's true but we don't like it it's
misinformation
this piece is a master class in the kind
of suppression the left wishes to use in
social media to shut down your ability
to access information
this authoritarian bull
pushed by your taxpayer dollars
apparently
it's just incredible so we're bad
we should we should be shut out i say in
the years since he left breitbart news
shapiro has carved out a rare niche
within the conservative media world the
graduate of harvard law school taps into
many of the same culture war themes that
former president donald trump played
into while also disagreeing with trump a
feat he's managed without becoming a
target of the former president's ire
shapiro has publicly denounced the
alt-right and other people in trump's
orbit like steve bannon
as well as the conspiracy theory trump
is the rightful winner of the 2020
election
but in the same column i wrote after the
violence on january 6
last week the capital was breached by a
group of french trump supporters who had
bought into a series of lies
but in the same column he quickly turned
his attention back to democrats and
their support of the nationwide black
lives matter protest last year
which many conservatives have falsely
sought to paint broadly as riot
he's been widely condemned for anti-lgbt
comments
oh my god wow so again i'm conservative
this means i'm bad
he's he's he's just i'm terrible and
then they quote a bunch of people who
don't like me
incredible really well done here so
basically the idea here is we should not
exist because we're good at our jobs
that's the entire article the entire
article is from npr dailywear should not
exist
and we're misinformation because they
disagree they're coming for your
information
they're coming for the outlets you like
they're coming to suppress them
this is one more reason why you should
support every outlet that you like
come subscribe at daily wire because
they're going to come after us they're
going to try and z platform us it's
something they are overtly making clear
they want to do right now so come
subscribe over at daily wire right now
also pick up a copy of my book all about
all of this and do it for other people
too
if you like the blaze go subscribe at
the blaze if you like fox nation go
subscribe at fox nation
seriously you need to subscribe to the
services you like because the left is
going to try to take them away they're
going to try to take neutral service
providers like facebook
and destroy them if they don't become
overt tools of the left
that's the goal it's despicable it's
authoritarian it's polarizing it's going
to destroy the country
they are responsible for the
polarization they are responsible for
tearing all of this apart they are
responsible for shutting down
any sort of rational realistic or decent
debate on these issues
and then they proclaim that they're in
favor of american unity and truth
yep how's this for a title ben shapiro
show subscriber destroys like button
with clicks and logic
i'd watch that make it happen gang